alright guys everyone's been asking for
this just literally so many people have
been asking for this so many comments so
many tweets so here it is
every West Dakota video at 100k wow
that's just like horrifying audio jeez
like I didn't think that this was going
to sound Pleasant but this is probably
like one of the more disturbing things
that I've ever audibly experienced oh
wow okay so this is some footage of
Dakota going to this protest this is
pretty recent and this is his shortest
video and we're going to be going from
his well they're all playing at once
every video is playing at once the
shortest videos are on top and the
longest videos are on the bottom so for
those of you who don't know what Dakota
he is he would probably describe himself
as a daily vlogger but I think it would
be more accurate to describe him as a
lifestyle blogger because he rarely ever
uploads everyday or even on consecutive
days
I think his motto is a like uploads most
days but that clearly never happened
to the point all right so here's the end
of his first video so now we're going to
see like the ends of all of his videos
because we've gotten through the first
one so once here's one thing that you'll
see a lot in what's the go-to videos he
loves to put in his traveling shots in
the car as transitions to everything I
think most of his videos are about 90%
travel shots and then 10% talking to the
point that he actually comes become
self-aware of it this is a different
this is the only non vlog video I'm
pretty sure because he did this sketch
about coming up with different ideas for
a sketch so exciting stuff there and
just in a moment here it's going to get
to the point where
he gets into like the regular length of
his vlog so we're just going to see like
the end of every video and there are a
lot of those title cards that say like
oh this was a really short vlog was a
really short vlog I didn't feel like
blogging today hey
this red shirt is also something that
we'll see a lot that's I believe his 1d
shirt from when he worked at Wendy's
which he just stopped working that
recently but anyway back to West Dakota
it's almost become yeah there it is
another short vlog it's almost become
kind of a meme that he just like he
considers himself to be just a lazy
daily vlogger but really like he
probably should not call himself a daily
vlogger because it's really more just to
become when he feels like it okay so
this right here is gonna be hilarious
Dakota's kitchen and we're going to
covering up the lens because that's how
he ends up every video and there was a
stretch for a long time where he was he
would do like a talk at the end of every
video in his kitchen and then he would
cover up the camera and another short
vlog I don't even know what this is like
this video is just ending with this shot
of the sink like the audio is so
inaudible that I can't tell what's going
on maybe it connects to this video I
don't know um it's totally ridiculous
but anyway the West Dakota is the genius
the mastermind
except behind such monumental vlogs such
as slightly epic montage that isn't very
epic slightly epic time lapse the most
underwhelming vlog ever this vlog is a
[ __ ] and of course the
masterpiece another boring day this shot
is actually at our College om you called
that bridesmaid films which I think you
most of you guys know him from my videos
and having collabs with me many times
before it's kind of funny watching this
from
the shortest videos for the longest
videos because it seems like the
different area the different eras rather
of West Dakota are kind of clumped
together like he was in the mood for a
while where he would just end every blog
like doing a talk to the camera with his
shirt off and then those all ended up
together because I guess he did the he
did similar length videos another short
vlog I think at this point after you've
done it like 20 times there's no point
in putting title card in there so over
time he's amassed over 320 subscribers
50 of what she got from doing the collab
with me on the first two episodes of
truth here and by the way if you hadn't
seen truth there no I'm kidding I'm not
going to plug that in this video
actually Who am I kidding yeah I am go
watch true fear it's a great series I
think you'll enjoy it so my original
idea for this and here's another just
crazy montage of discovering up the
camera my original idea for this video
would be that it would literally just be
all of his vlogs at once like they were
transparent on top of one another but
others pretty cool yeah the great flood
so I want them to all be transparent but
the only issue was it we can take about
10 days to render and I have actual
important videos to work on so that
wasn't going to happen I mean this video
will probably do better than those
videos that I actually put effort into
because that's the cruel reality of how
YouTube works but yeah once I figured
out that overlaying them all wasn't
going to work I just decided to line
them up from shortest to longest and
play them all through at one and he has
n screens on most of his videos and I
did take those out otherwise we'd be
watching mainly just end cards the end
cards that you do see are like ones that
come before his usual end card to set
makes any sense he ends every video
saying like a vlog 22 is over
but sometimes he puts a little message
before that so if you put a message I've
left it in for comedic value mostly I
don't know what happened here
um actually I probably did that when I
was like I probably accidentally not not
that a clip over and after effect well
yeah I left the messages in there
because like crystal repetitive it's
either him complaining that like he
doesn't have motivation or complaining
that his vlog was short which again is
his fault and or saying like oh well my
battery died so I'm just going to end it
here
and that happened surprisingly like a
lot I'll see if I can point it out
because sometimes it'll just flash on
screen really quickly so I where what
was I talking about so I took out the
end cards because I thought that might
be slightly more interesting than I
thought it would be slightly more
interesting to watch just a bunch of
shots of him covering up the camera as
opposed to just white text on a black
screen maybe not maybe not you guys can
let me know in the comments or something
wow this clips been going on for a while
every now and then will be like a really
abnormal length vlog and that's usually
one of his older ones and kind of
interesting listening to the audio now
because it turns from just like complete
utter wretched chaos to just kind of
like voila and if you guys don't know
what wallah is it's basically a film
term that we used to describe just like
that sound effect of people talking in a
crowded room when like you can't quite
understand what anybody's saying you
know what I'm talking about
but the really disturbing thing right
here it's just knowing that this is and
he says right here he wishes he talked
to the camera more and I think he
actually addresses that later on and
and does talk to the camera more Oh a
lot would reach would be a section where
they're not considered long vlogs by
Dakota but yeah the really disturbing
thing about this wala is just thinking
about it and knowing that it's all
Dakota's boy like usually when you
record while you have like a bunch of
people in a room just talking gibberish
and stuff but just knowing the fact that
it's all West Dakota it's like at this
point probably like 30 or 40 copies of
West Dakota just talking it just like
pretty much chilled me to the core dude
and now we've gotten to the point where
there are a few enough videos that you
can kind of make out some music in the
back oh this is a I think that those
fireworks are from the end of his VidCon
vlog which I was their special note
about the VidCon vlog my favorite moment
in West Dakota history is the I believe
it's the first VidCon vlog so he's
getting ready to leave and he's actually
getting ready to leave his house to go
over to my house where we were meeting
up before we headed down to you Anaheim
for the event and he just does this
thing I don't think it appears in this
because it's not towards the end this
vlog there's another traveling shot but
I like he starts playing this dubstep
music and then he just cuts to like all
these shots of his dogs and it's still
funny and I've dubbed it via the West
Dakota dubstep dogs and it's become just
like another meme among all of our
friends and we're always trying to get
him to like put another dubstep dogs it
just so funny is like zooming in shots
of dogs / dubstep I don't know I don't
why I find it funny but it's hilarious
to me so I was actually supposed to meet
up with Dakota today because I was going
to edit a short city shot because that's
what I do I'm a video editor here's what
more of the VidCon stuff good stuff you
see our friends Blake and AJ from
factoids films and you see me there on
the left a little bit but yeah I was
going to head over there and edit a
short study shot
and it was a little late it was like
11:40 I think we said we'd meet up
sometime after 11:00 so I just came over
there straight from this other job I was
doing and I give him a call and it goes
straight to voicemail
okay I don't know if you guys noticed
that right there but I actually heard
someone in the background state Dakota
so we're actually at the point where
there are a few enough videos that I can
kind of hear some of the audio
interesting so I was just immediately
disappointed in him when he didn't pick
up
so I basically told myself I would call
him one more time and just like I was
out of there if you didn't pick up at
that point because like I'm important I
value my time oh god this is so cringy
why did you put this in here Dakota um
so I wasn't going to let West Dakota
waste my time and here's the thing and
this goes for West Dakota or anybody
else when sees these worlds calls you
you immediately pick it up once these
world calls you you don't even let it
get to the third ring I don't care if
you're live streaming I don't care if
you're taking a dump I don't care if
you're jerking it off which is probably
what the West Dakota was doing to be
honest I don't care if you're disposing
of a dead hooker or a dead gangster even
if you yourself are dead because when
fifties world calls to you you got to
pick it up because I won't stand for my
time being waste I think they're talking
about the dubstep dogs are here yeah
okay so I think they're trying to get
him to put dubstep dogs in this video
and he wasn't talking to it yeah and he
called me out there and says no I'm not
going to put the dubstep dogs he hates
that that's like the best part of the
videos but you know it's true Dakota um
and while we've we've already gotten to
the end um so yeah this has been every
West Dakota video at once
thank you all for requesting this and
yeah
[Music]